peu
[Musique]
e
bah
[Musique]
on
pour
[Musique]
et
billet s'il vous plaît quel est le
premier des rois le premier des rois et
bâle démontré ses fall qui a une dans la
partie orientale de l'enfer combien de
les gens comment ont-ils à 66
les voici la clé la voiture est là
voilà le plan toile au garage garage
rideau rue du pont à chantons le vieil
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
gagner le premier roi
premier lit roy evans
le démon tricéphale qui règne dans la
partie orientale de l'enfer à combien de
légion commentaires à 66 ouais la
voiture du journaliste
[Musique]
j'ai réfléchi choque pas quelle est la
sanction pour ceux qui trahissent le
serment des compagnons baloo la mort
où est la voiture
j'assure conjoncture a vraiment l'air
d'un accident
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
gérard morel journaliste prisé pour
louper insu quand un éclatement on a
beau leur dire de faire vérifier dans
tenu à la vitesse où il allait d'après
les traces sur la route y faisait au
moins 240
sur la piste lors le prendriez si à la
plage irait gérard morel essayer de
résoudre un problème sur lequel la
police se casse les dents depuis 10 ans
et ça ça me plairait drôlement à
vocation m'est venue en lisant fantômas
je me voyais déjà un journaliste
héroïque
steele et jérôme fandor et puis total je
peux les chiens écrasés la main quand
j'étais gosse mon rêve c'était de
reporter tout ça parce que j'avais lu ou
le ta vie puis quand j'ai eu mon
certificat
il fallait gagner sa croûte je rentrais
comme grouillot au journal
en attendant de pouvoir réaliser mes
rêves tu m' attends je fais le site car
j'attends toujours ma chance et moi
aussi ça fait partie du métier les
enfants regardent c'est ma femme
là ma fille dit liliane vous me l'avez
déjà montré plus de 100 fois cela
pourrait la reverrai ma petite liliane
quand j'aurai trouvé un homme club
tu pourras dire toute la vérité mais
encore une taxe
cela tient pour la mine faut que j ai
tapé là il arrive pourtant pis aller au
revoir mais moi seule la prochaine fois
quand vous aurez payé celui d'avant on
verra comment la plus confiance en moi
tu sais bien je te prêt à aller au bout
de trois mois comme la dernière fois
et pendant ce temps là c'est moi qui me
fais engueuler par le gérant tuer n'est
qu'un jeu tordu hâte de renouveler ma
consommation
larbin et didon diogène j'ai
l'impression que tu as encore plongé
dans son tonneau 3 méfie toi je me
plaindre à la direction et au ram et
nouvelle encore le bras à londres je
sais qu'un de toi et tu présenter une
plaisanterie je n'admettrai jamais comme
tim morse permet de copier d'arnaud
venir ceci n'a aucune importance
comment au tulle important mais non mais
non
bush et d'arnaud j'ai cru comprendre que
vous étiez un peu gêné pour le moment
alors messi il faut peut-être un jour ou
l'autre et nous serons kit home studio
[Musique]
extraordinaire et peut-être qu'un jour
je sais malin si on peut plus rigoler
d'un clodo maintenant ce clodo comme tu
dis c'est jacques d'arnaud c'est quoi
jacques d'arnaud un très grand
journaliste enfin c'était je te souhaite
une carrière aussi brillante que la
sienne sur le plan professionnel il ya
deux types que j'ai admiré dans ma vie
c'est albert londres et lui je ne savais
pas mais qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé je
n'étais pas encore au journal demande à
pépère et tout ira mieux que moi aux
vagues ya à peu près une dizaine
d'années à la fin de l'été mathias était
un mois ou deux avant la sphère du
fourgon postal du vol des trois cents
kilos d'or
l' affaire sur laquelle le bord elle
travaille actuellement et lui été retenu
à paris pour une enquête dont il n'a
voulu parler à personne
sa femme et sa petite fille de 8 ans
vous voyez en braathen qu'on lui une
promenade en mer et il en fera
un accident pour monsieur harnois un
bien triste accident
et moins
moi je ne lui a rien dit en fin
d'après-midi des pêcheurs qui allait
poser des filets ont trouvé la barque
retourner le cadavre de la jeune femme a
été rejeté par la mer trois jours après
quand elle aux marins qui les
accompagnent et nous a jamais retrouvé
il les aimait très profondément il
vivait que pour elle le chagrin était
telle que sa raison n'y a pas résisté
r il te puis s'est mis à boire et y est
devenu ce que tu vois quand je suis
arrivé au journal on espérait encore qui
s'en tirerait il fait encore illusion
ppr a fait tout ce qu'il a pu pour
l'aider mais est pourquoi on l'appelle
diogène par une cherche à nam il rêve de
trouver un héros une sorte de parsifal
ou de superman formidable secret tout
accomplir on ne sait quelle horrible
vengeance
[Musique]
mayroy le patron te demander retrouve
encore à chiens écrasés non kutwa c'est
sérieux borel vient de se tuer en
voiture quoi il paraît que c'est toi qui
le remplace
[Musique]
et petit à petit
tu as toujours été si cake ces derniers
[Musique]
j'attends maintenant mais c'est
dernièrement secret
[Musique]
et
on
le secret des compagnons pas une autre
femme jaya je suis très très pressé je
ne crois pas mais si mais si le patron
marc changent
non tu me proposes
[Musique]
on ne pourra pas dire j'aime
ah ah
[Musique]
jugant go
oh
[Musique]
quel est le châtiment pour ceux qui
aiment la loi du silence imposée paris
on de mal
et
la mort
[Musique]
où
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais oui surcroît konan mais oui vous
pourrez attendre cinq minutes non je
viens d'apprendre pour regarder vos
condoléances et vous qui le remplacer
que savez vous du top de bien gérer ce
que morel on ne racontait pas ses
papiers il y a dix ans un train postal a
été attaquée près de gland j'irai dans
le jura pas loin de la frontière suisse
les gangsters ont réussi à remporter
trois cents kilos d'or et alors oui ben
j'arrive te tuer regardez ça il faut que
j'aille au marbre et au nez
vous l'avez terre il pourra vous
renseigner je suis occupé de la faire à
l'époque
je me permets d'insister encore
mademoiselle françoise ce paquet doit
être remis en main propre et dans le
plus grand secret surtout vis-à-vis de
la famille à madame roche 40 rue haute à
mouchard vous savez ce que sont les
dernières volontés de mon pauvre du
tillay comme son ami toujours et son
notaire
je lui ai promis les accomplir hélas ma
santé ne me permet plus voyage et en
dehors de guidon mon premier est clair
qu'ils vont guère mieux que moi vous
êtes la seule personne à qui je puisse
confier une semblable mission j'imagine
qu'il s'agit des lettres d'amour qu'une
jeune dame en robe à volants écrit mais
il ya 50 ans à lieutenant de hussards la
ville les a séparés il les a gardés
pieusement et après sa mort il les lui
fait rendre c'est une façon de lui dire
qu'il a toujours pensé à elle jusqu'au
dernier moment pour une jeune femme
moderne
vous êtes bien romantique non d'utiliser
n'a jamais été une star il était
confiseurs et territoriales en 14
mais ce n'est pas une raison et madame
roche était bien jolie dans sa robe à
volants soyez tranquilles m le secret
sera bien gardé
[Applaudissements]
un transfert de la banque de france à la
banque fédérale suisse trois cents kilos
d'or en lingots et on n'a jamais rien
trouvé ni l'heure ni les gangsters
absolument rien c'ets volatilisé et a
pas idée du chabanais que ça fait dans
la région oui le bruit avait couru que
le magot étaient cachés sur place alors
les paysans du coin se sont mis à la
chasse au trésor ça fait des bagarres
dans les familles entre familles mais
même entre villages sans compter les
lettres anonymes
mais pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas toi
qu'on envoie là-bas puisque tu connais
toute la sphère ouais tu sais moi
maintenant les déplacements je laisse ça
aux jeunes ça y est vous êtes au courant
et bien sauté dans votre bagnole défilé
à la gendarmerie de château le fait que
c'est que ma voiture j'ai eu un
accrochage est bien prenez le train de
notre niveau stats et un côté sombre
monsieur soit près d'un petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un portois ingouche mon frein pour qu'un
cul comme sur moi
[Musique]
suite pas de trucs
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on y est
le
je vais faire
et
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
e
bon
[Musique]
moi au vol air france
e
quand
on
oh
[Musique]
on
tant pis pour vous vous avez été trop
curieux
songez à ce qui est arrivé aux femmes de
barbe bleue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le chargement est terminée oui net
elle est par ici ramallah vers la route
je mets les autres en chasse dès que je
n'ai plus besoin du entendu m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rattraper cette fille est supprimée là
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
à
on
non
[Musique]
yes to play quel est le premier des rois
le premier des rois et bâle le démon
tricéphale qui règne sur la partie
orientale de l'enfer là combien de
légion commandes team 60
la voiture est là le maître vous attend
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
un gérant le risque c'est tout mais pas
autant baissé depuis
on a voulu me tuer moi par sévit dans le
bois qu'ils ont pris ma voiture
ben c'est pas de chance mais y'a d'la
giresse il faudrait à des achats soldes
y avait tout de même quelqu'un paris
pourront histoire on a le devoir
j'ai le maire et qu'il me soit permis
tout en formulant des voeux pour votre
bonheur en forme et d'un autre pour le
bonheur de tous
je souhaite qu'il y ait souvent temps
toutes les communes de notre belle
patrie de beaucoup d'union aussi belle
aussi noble que celle que nous venons de
célébrer aujourd'hui
soyez de bons c'est lui l'homme de cette
nuit s'est lui rapproché par n'approchez
pas
pour koné et son défaut la gendarmerie
vestiaires paul conduisait mademoiselle
à château le vieil voulez vous si vous
avez du retard dans votre tournée sont
ou seraient un nom à votre patron
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il dit pas le seul maire quand on a
trouvé le fou est ce qu'on a une prise
au jeu ne compte pas mon protocole
enfin à moins que la famille on me suit
c'est le cas je m'en occuperai
on
cette fois ci elle tape échappera trois
[Musique]
jours les enfants bonjour maintenant
bonjour m
carmat
c'est un accident n'y a pas de doute
penser votre collègue borel il roulait à
au moins 140 à l'heure avec un pneu
arrière gauche complètement usés alors
comme ça vous allez parler de moi dans
votre journal bien sûr vous étiez déjà
là au moment du hold up
c'est à dire pas exactement à ce moment
là j'étais simple gendarme à frétigné
mais alors on nous a menés ici au moment
de la sphère du fourgon postal
trois cents kilos d'or venait d'un seul
coup pensé ça fait du bruit
nous avons prié partout dans le pays
mais walid chammah de fer fish en trois
semaines qu'on assure si on n'est pas
arrivé à mettre la main sur ces saletés
chargement d'or
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez votre chef
mais ses clochettes il a occupé les avec
un journaliste de paris il a dit qu'on
ne dérange pas c'est pourquoi on a voulu
me tuer on a essayé de voler ma voiture
est ce que c'est suffisant pour que vous
consenti à faire votre métier aux biens
bien ma petite dame calmez-vous givet
suivez moi entrer chef c'est une femme
qui prétend qu'elle a été victime d'une
tentative d'assassinât
et qui dit qu'on lui a volé sa voiture
il fallait rentrer tu t'attends bien
j'ai fait à quel métier on n'a pas nui
da soit je voudrais pas vous déranger
indiqué non seulement s'opposant chez
même pas du tout pas du tout rester je
vous en prie et puis ce qui intéressera
peut-être voir comment nous travaillons
en province
basa je vous écoute prenons adresse
qualité françoise cordier secrétaire m
sans pas vers nos terres 8
occupez vous du dispositif de sécurité
ce sera fait m alain robert retourner à
la mairie et détruisez tout ce qui
pourrait nous compromettre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les bandits masqués ont disparu au
chant du coq
oui le jour seuls veille alors que comme
les fantômes les spectres dans les
comptes de ma grand-mère alors
mademoiselle
comment voulez vous je vous croire vous
arrivez on ne sait comment dans un pays
où personne ne vous connais vous me
racontez des histoires à dormir debout
et vous porter des accusations
extrêmement graves contre l'un des
hommes les plus considérables de la
région
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe mais il ya un
pépin le biais de l'homme arrivé ce
matin la garde et bien sûr bon tu besoin
de toi petit pète c'est pas grave au
moins c'est toujours ce soir qu'on aura
nos parts oui c'est hulk est ce que je
vais dire
je ne sais même pas qui vous êtes
comme je viens de vous le dire oui je
sais vous appelez france passe cordier
et vous vous rendez amoucha en voyage
d'agréement seulement vous n'avez aucun
papier d'identité
mais puisque je vous dis que j'ai perdu
mon sac en défendant contre cet homme et
tenez voilà les clés de la voiture
ça tombe bien j'en avais une ça prouve
seulement que vous avez des clés de
voiture dans votre poche
un point c'est tout les gens sont
extraordinaires et bien fait une enquête
je vous répète que je porte plainte pour
tentative de meurtre et pour vol c'est
ça alors à cause de vos lubies
je vais aller chercher des ennuis un des
hommes qui est à tu et à toi avec tout
le gratin du département et qui
déjeunent si le préfet et moi ma ptite
dame
je tiens à mon amant
[Musique]
c'est là le maire de blain j'irai qui
s'amène sur un lac
je viens tout de suite et bien mis sur
votre assassin et là nous allons pouvoir
tirer tout cela au clair monsieur je
vous jure que je dis la vérité
si je peux vous aider en quoi que ce
soit mademoiselle compter sur moi je le
ferai
merci monsieur
aujourd'hui j'ai deux places en mesure
aurait un jour vraiment monsieur est un
journaliste de paris claude leroi de
france me dit enchanté asseyez-vous mais
cette passion je vous en prie monsieur
laurent a fait une enquête au sujet de
l'or vous savez bien il ya dix ans ah
oui c'est une vieille histoire
monsieur j'espère que votre journal ne
donnera pas une publicité intempestive
au regrettable incident qui vient de se
produire dans ma petite commune blain
gyr est ordinairement fort paisible
je me suis livrée moi même à une petite
enquête à propos de cette malheureuse et
j'ai pensé qu'il était préférable de
vous en parler avant que les racontars
se mettent à circuler
la vérité est tristement simple cette
jeune femme est arrivée à blain j'irai
ce matin par la micheline de 7
comment mais mouret vous racontera cela
mieux que moi il est en train de vouloir
me faire passer pour folle silence les
séparer les témoins allez-y morel et ben
voilà vous savez qu'un blanc giresse est
pas une guerre juste une halte assez
loin les pays donc à 7h ce matin
voilà la machine qui s'arrête et moi
j'étais étonné vu que ça n'arrive que le
vendredi pour prendre les gens qui vont
au marché ou quelquefois à l'été quand
il ya des vacances il est pierrine donc
elle s'arrête
et voilà cette demoiselle qui en descend
aux oreilles qui en descend comme ça
sans bagages elle avait l'air tout drôle
et puis au lieu de ponte par la route
la voilà partie d'avant tel tout droit à
travers champs il ment puisque je vous
dis que je suis arrivé en voiture je le
bien du tout le même et même tu en voilà
son billet qu'elle m'a donné et même que
ça m'a étonné vu qu'il est pour aller à
lausanne
minimes en filant à non je ne me tairais
pas si vous croyez je veux blesser pour
vous vous trompez mais si l'os
on s'est vraiment je crois qu'il vaut
mieux que je parte ma présence ne vaut
rien
je ne suis pas malade et vous le savez
cette nuit vous avez essayé de
m'assassiner vous avez volé ma voiture
mais vous verrez année mademoiselle
[Musique]
allons
soyez calme
k
[Musique]
je ne sais plus
je ne sais plus personne ne veut qu il
veut croire
[Musique]
maintenant vous savez mieux que moi ce
qu'il vous reste à faire
bon vous allez bien bouclée j'avais fait
drôlement froid dans les cellules
elle va travailler la terre vous avez
raison piedoie elle serait cruel
d'ajouter aux souffrances de cette
pauvre enfant
mais qu'est ce que les gens fassent si
on la mettait dans la chambre du nouveau
puisqu'il arrive pendant trois jours
enfin je marche
cette chambre présentes elles toutes les
garanties de sécurité je me sens un peu
responsable
ça vous pouvez 30 il ya pas de danse y
est je viens dans ce cas c'est parfait
parce que je peux compter sur votre
discrétion cette malheureuse a
certainement une famille un père et une
mère qui aurait le coeur brisé s'il
infirmité de leurs enfants étaient
livrés à la moquerie du public comptait
sur moi monsieur
si vous le permettez j'aurai l'honneur
de vous rendre visite cet après midi
pour les besoins de mon reportage
je ne vous serait malheureusement
d'aucun secours je n'habitais pas à
avelin j'irai au moment des événements
et jean c'est certainement beaucoup
moins que vous à ce sujet de plus j'ai
beaucoup à faire car ma matinée a été
perdu à cause de cette triste affaire
excusez moi je regrette monsieur
prenez mon rêve vraiment montrez-moi la
fenêtre de cette chambre je partirai
plus tranquille mais avec plaisir
mozilla plaçant dites moi il ya
longtemps qu'ils habitent blain giresse
monsieur de places en six ou sept ans
mais ils n'habitent pas tous dans la
même le plus souvent il est à paris pour
ses affaires quel genre d'affaires je
fais affaire
voyez c'était peut être là où il n'y a
pas de danger en effet
[Applaudissements]
voilà tout à fait rassuré
s'cusez moi de vous avoir dérangé mais
pas du tout cette plaçant ainsi nous
allons avoir un nouveau gendarme
oui dans trois jours il arrive des
cadors comment s'appelle-t-il bruce hack
jules moussac g de brossac
eh bien on va enfin man à aproport
pourrez vous n'oublierez pas de donner
le billet au moins gagné qu'à monsieur
le maire aux femmes cette façon
[Applaudissements]
il a voulu me tuer il a voulu les gens
sur locaux du trait on s'en fait une
petit mémento pas vraiment un
vous allez boucler la demoiselle avant
qu'on sache exactement qui allait aller
montrer relativement doucement doucement
alors mademoiselle vous inquiétez pas je
suis sûr que tout va s'arranger sera l'
affaire de quelques heures mais avec nos
valeurs car ils ont traîné ça vous
aidera à passer le temps merci monsieur
[Musique]
alors ici c'est paul passe mal à partir
attends une minute la préfecture ces
familles
[Musique]
alors
toujours occupée non tu me rappelles
d'accès libre et si vous téléphonez
directement à paris chez le notaire en
question vous saurez tout tout fixer sa
gagnerait du temps possible mais moi je
vois d'abord en référé à mes supérieurs
la voie hiérarchique moi je connais que
ça et puis comme ça je suis couvert ils
ont pied droit devrait porter une tasse
de café à demoiselle et puis tu dire à
ta femme qui lui face à manger à midi
yacef voyez pas une bicyclette à me
prêter pour le jusqu'à blanc givré et
dont voulait pas l'intention de forer
voter dans cette histoire j'espère jeu
pendant lui comme si la place en moi ce
qui est tranquille je voudrais seulement
jeté un coup d'oeil l'endroit où le hold
up a eu lieu pour l'ambiance de mon
article pour l'atmosphère boîte macias
est différent alors on peut reprendre
une d'or contre le mur n'importe
laquelle
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la voir
[Musique]
alors moi je le regrette
maurus terje presse parisienne elle abat
jane plus après ça moi j'aurais plus mon
con non et
brooks et la mort dans le crash du
brabant que c'est claude claude mainon
c'est par espèce de cinglés qui s'est
jetée par la fenêtre de son compartiment
pourquoi veux tu que cloud
la rugueuse avec ruse leurs trois-quarts
pensé que c'était une maquette du prince
chez bras comme ça rien dire
et j'ai rien à dire et puis arrête comme
tourmenté non je t'en supplie si tu sais
quelque chose de grave au sujet clos
pour me le dire j'ai rien et vas-y
[Musique]
oh
dir et tu sais quelque chose avait la
carte et se prête
tu me dégoûtes claude a toujours été
gentil avec toi il a toujours fait ce
qu'il a pu pour aider et c'est comme ça
que tu ne remercie c'est même plus un
homme
on est en danger en grand danger contre
coria pour lui même mois
et basta c'est ce combat maire albert
reconnaît mon secteur
pourquoi bon tu pas ma place avec un
vent chaud avec les copains
oh
non aucune commission merci beaucoup
monsieur moyens qu'avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel est le premier des rois le premier
des rois et bat le démontrer centrale
qui règne dans la partie orientale de
l'enfer reconstitution grandeur il
commanda 66 légion ici le maître
j'écoute m le journaliste vient de
téléphoner à paris chez m champs pas
vers nos terres il a demandé à parler à
mademoiselle françoise cordier
c'est bien ça suffit
m
partage
ouais
[Musique]
m j'ai l'impression que c'est un v6 de
journaliste est en train de se mêler de
ce qui ne le regarde pas tout il s'en
débarrasser ce n'est pas lui qui est
dangereux c'est la fille elle m'a vue
cette nuit
cette fois ci il faut la supprimer avant
de partir
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
et là claude le roy le journaliste oui
je vous écoute par l'amba brigadier
serait furieux s'il me trouver ici j'ai
téléphoné à paris chez métro chemin vert
et j'ai demandé à parler à mademoiselle
cordier et alors on m'a répondu que
l'état en voyage pour le moment et j'ai
appris qu'il était parti en voiture
ah vous voyez bien vous l'avais dit au
brigadier certainement pas me donner
l'ordre ou presque de ne pas me mêler
cette histoire il avait une peur bleue
de votre assassin
pendant ce temps là cette crapule fait
ce qu'elle veut et moi je suis enfermé
ici
par ailleurs depuis le biais de chemin
de fer il est parfaitement en règle et
il a été délivré hier soir à paris et
bien quelqu'un d'autre s'en est servi
c'est évident mais si vous dites la
vérité il faut bien que quelqu'un
mentent pas les dire deux mots garde
barrière pourquoi tout ça je vous
raconterai plus tard il ya trois cents
kilos d'or volée que doivent se trouver
quelque part dans la région depuis dix
ans et je pense qu'un cercueil n'est pas
non plus resté chez d'aucune autre
courage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
souffler n'est pas jouer la seconde
seconde seconde j'ai pas encore lent
chez mon pion à 6 ans née sous x c'est
facile de raidisseurs rapport avec vous
deux qu'est ce que c'est encore entrés
ces messieurs dames c'est vrai ça c'est
ici oui c'est ici et c'est voulu voler
on a tapé un livre et un tapis
oui il a commandé un tapis on est les
galeries modernes la plénière c'est
bruce a que ce sera quand trois jours on
n'a qu'à laisser votre tapis dans le
couloir dans le couloir et s'il arrive
un accident c'est qu'on les responsables
de ace combat parlementaire lui mais
chez lui à quelqu'un en fichez la paix
gotta be
voyez par j'ai du travail mais il n'y a
qu'elle laissait devant sa porte qui
risquent rien
normalement on veut bien si ça s'est
vérifié mais je vais leur montrer chez
alesi alesi qu'on suivait mois
et là où il est bien on est tranquille
bon ça fait ça fait 250 mille francs
quoi 250000 belle pour un tapis comme
c'est un tapis d'origine
un gendarme qui se paie des tapis
d'origine déjà vu sa toile vous faites à
jacou vous payer en liquide à qui ça moi
d'abord j'ai pas 250 mille francs mais
bien mais si je les appelle ils
retournent des calques alpages gros
tapis pas moi en tout cas non du moi non
plus vous n'avez qu'à demander à votre
bruce hack main si vous ne payez pas
être forcés de l'emporter c'est payable
à la livraison
bon alors c'est fini c'est sur le tapis
vous voyez succès à faire moi alors
remporté le sus à vous amuse et foutez
moi la paix ça va ça va ça va je vous
pensais pas il doit y avoir une erreur
quelque part on va l'emporter le tapis
vous dénoncez pas on connaît le chemin
de 150 me moi si j'avais les moyens de
mettre 250 mille francs dans un tapis je
serai pas long d'armes en tout cas il va
trop le mans se régaler de bruce hack
quand il m'arrivait
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]